monsieur et madame la commune sont
mariés depuis 50 ans il y a dix ans
madame commune est déclarée concernées
par la maladie d'alzheimer depuis deux
ans l'état de madame l'eau mines s'est
dégradée elle est concernée par des
troubles sévères son mari s'occupe dead
chaque jour et il assiste à l'avancement
progressif de cette maladie
neurodégénérative
oui
messieurs c'est à dire
non script pas morose et
tout d'un coup
tellement
6 à l'auto finissent pourtant bel et
bien
de la chance parce qu'on espère ouvrir
la bouche
c'est bien
lui le dollar d'ici là là il pèse 57 kg
soit 10 environ et pèse 60 kg 100 kg et
maintenant il ya des gens dans son
concept qui descend plus que pour monter
ses parents la maladie d'alzheimer peut
également provoquer des troubles du
comportement
une dépendance qui exige une vigilance
permanente de monsieur l'oms
la cité
el amari dernière ne suffit pas suffi de
même et
circonstances qui a bon parce que l
qu'aux étudiants auxquels il a fait
plusieurs fois un pansement le camp bon
le coudekerquois ni dans la maison
répond le six jours la coupe de cheveux
téléphone j'ai comme j'ai fait les
ventes et la terre il rit vincent comme
11 ans qui sont à ta petite étape qui va
grandement je pense qu'ils portent au
net ils rendent à salle de bain il prend
la bouteille son point la balle est
alors bien en ce moment et
adam laumes une est accompagné par un
service d'aidé à domicile
en plus de la médecine de ville ils
n'affirment y revient une fois par jour
ainsi qu'une assistante de vie sociale
qui l'accompagnent dans les tâches
quotidiennes il pourrait bénéficier
d'une aide journalières supplémentaires
mais monsieur commune souhaite s'occuper
de son épouse
mary mais si les pontons des
mbp monsieur law mule qui a passé les 80
ans s'occupe de son épouse chaque jour
il est parfois épuisés il a lui aussi
besoin de soutien c'est pourquoi il
s'est tourné vers l'association france
alzheimer réunion qui propose plusieurs
activités de soutien aux aidants
familiaux des est arrivé complètement
désemparé complètement épuisé
physiquement psychologiquement
et je les vois cheminée en fait de les
voir cheminée et au fur et à mesure il
arrive à s'adapter parce qu'il faut
s'adapter tout le temps c'est une
maladie qui évolue donc quelque chose
comme est en place maintenant dans six
mois bah vous soit obligé de changer et
je les vois où ils évoluent ils me
comprennent mieux la maladie mieux leurs
proches et il arrive à s'adapter
et en général ça va mieux ça les aide
souvent j10 c'est la soupape de sécurité
le groupe de parole des groupes et oui
sa part alain juppé ou
mai
mais c'est pas médicaments
par ben non je suis par contre
n'en ai pas tous les artistes ou de
congés payés il attendait pas sa sortie
est un rendez-vous est dopée par lés le
plus difficile pour lui c'est
d'isolement maladie d'alzheimer accapare
beaucoup de tours de prise en charge et
a souvent pour effet d'isoler les dons
principal cette solitude c'est peut-être
ce qui pèse le plus monsieur l'homme une
bassine on
n'est pas là moi tout seul les
compagnies il ya madame non seulement il
vient là
s'éloigne doucement doucement parce que
je sais pas la maladie leur fait peur je
vous ai dit tout à l'heure la personne
change de personnalité
les aidants au fanal
les personnes de la famille ou les amis
ne reconnaissent plus la personne qu'ils
ont connue dans la personne malade parce
qu'elle a trop changé
il est plus vous fera mesure doucement
mais sûrement pour monde l'entourage
s'éloigne face aux besoins de prise en
charge de madame l'onu une solution
serait sont accueillis en établissements
spécialisés
un ehpad mais en dépit des difficultés
monsieur l'oms a bien l'intention de
s'occuper de son épouse jusqu'au bout on
en
est déjà à peine place et les
polypensionnés connaissance gp et se
tenait en respect les affaires mais
c'est pas facile de demander de l'aide
c'est culpabilisant aussi de se dire par
exemple
balaj y arrive plus vraiment j'ai fait
tout ce que je pouvais je suis au bout
de mes ressources il faudrait peut-être
que j'envisage de placer
la personne dont je m'occupe par exemple
en ehpad c'est très culpabilisant donc
tout ça fait qu'il continue qui continue
c'est un bon ami que j'admire
franchement je l'admirais pour tout ce
qui fait quoi secours pour madame du
matin au soir la nuit dont quelques
failles arrive
qui m'appelle au secours si la personne
appelée il m'appelle mais si je suis pas
occupé j'arrive je viens mais sinon
tout fait après sa femme mais je trouve
ça formidable à 80 ans passés monsieur
paul commune fait face à cette nouvelle
épreuve de la vie elle continue de jouer
à la mandoline les airs favoris de son
épouse une mélodie du présent qui les
lie semble-t-il pour toujours
combien